منحت شبكة CNN الأجنبية حق الوصول الحصري إلى
منطقة الخطر على متن حاملة الطائرات العملاقة USS
George H.W Bush لمشاهدة جزء من
أكبر مناورة عسكرية أمريكية وإسرائيلية مشتركة على الإطلاق
تغطي جميع جوانب
الحرب من الجو
إلى الأرض
إلى البحر
عبر الإنترنت وحتى في الفضاء.
ليس من قبيل الصدفة إرسال
إشارة واضحة إلى إيران والخصوم الآخرين
في المنطقة مفادها أنه على الرغم من
الاهتمام بأوكرانيا ومخاوف الولايات المتحدة
بشأن الحكومة الإسرائيلية اليمينية الجديدة، إلا أن
الأمريكيين يظلون
متحالفين بشدة وملتزمين
بشراكة عسكرية مع إسرائيل من أجل
الأمريكيين.  والإسرائيليون هذه الأنواع
من التدريبات هي استعراض للقوة، واستعراض
للشراكة، ووسيلة لكلاهما
ليُظهرا للعالم أنهما قادران على
المشي ومضغ العلكة في نفس الوقت،
فقط من خلال الالتزام الراسخ بهذه
الشراكة، فهل نستطيع ذلك؟  لتخطيط
وتنظيم مثل هذه العملية المتطورة المعقدة بشكل لا يصدق
مع العديد من العناصر
عبر هذه المنطقة الجغرافية الكبيرة
ضد جميع جوانب القتال،
والتي يُرى أن بعضها لا يناسب
الإسرائيليين، فإن التمرين أمر بالغ الأهمية لقد
عارضوا منذ فترة طويلة  العودة إلى
الاتفاق النووي الإيراني، وجادلوا
بأن التهديد العسكري الحقيقي يجب أن
يكون مطروحًا على الطاولة لردع إيران عن
تطوير سلاح نووي بالكامل. وتتقاسم إسرائيل في
الولايات المتحدة
نفس القيم التي يتقاسمها جيش
الدفاع الإسرائيلي والقيادة المركزية الأمريكية تجاه
التهديدات في هذا الشأن.  في المنطقة، انضم أكثر من 6400
جندي أمريكي إلى 1100 إسرائيلي
كجزء من هذه التدريبات التي تستخدم
أكثر من 142 طائرة بما في ذلك طائرات
F-18، وبينما يقوم الإسرائيليون
والأمريكيون بانتظام بإجراء
تدريبات مشتركة حولت هذه التدريبات التركيز
أكثر إلى الهجوم بدلاً من
الدفاع فقط.  لقد تم تجميع القدرات أيضًا
في شهرين فقط بسرعة لا تصدق،
خاصة بالنسبة لشيء بهذا
الحجم مقارنة بعام نموذجي أو نحو ذلك من
التخطيط بينما يخجل المسؤولون
من الربط المباشر بين
السرعة والأحداث الأخيرة في إيران
وانهيار المفاوضات في العام الماضي.
فيما يتعلق بالاتفاق النووي، من الصعب
تجاهل السياق. أعتقد أنه من
الواضح إلى حد ما أنه يمكننا نقل الأصول بسرعة كبيرة
في المنطقة للاستجابة
للأزمة، ويمكننا القيام بذلك جنبًا إلى جنب مع
شركائنا، ويمكننا القتال والقيام
بعمليات هجومية في كل مجال
جنبًا إلى جنب.  يبدو أن شركائنا
الخيار العسكري الذي وصفه الرئيس بايدن بأنه
الملاذ الأخير للتعامل مع إيران معروض بصوت
عالٍ
على متن سفينة يو إس إس جورج إتش
دبليو بوش.